Americans Coast to Coast feeling the
impact of the worsening crisis at our
Southern border places like Chicago New
York and Massachusetts declaring
emergencies over the migrant influx
despite being thousands of miles from
the border let's bring our panel Chicago
resident Sam Sanchez also on the board
of National Restaurant Association
Brownsville Texas resident Deborah Bell
also candidate for Cameron County GOP
chair and Brooklyn resident Ashanti
Harding also an elementary school
teacher you know I'd love to actually
I'm going to start with you Ashanti one
of the things that I've noticed um you
know I spent a great amount of my time
in New York although I live in Texas and
in New York for me Ashanti it has been a
visible difference over the last several
years the presence of illegal immigrants
within the community has that been your
experience do you see a big change just
in your life over the last three
years yes definitely in my life because
as I as you said I am a teacher and a
lot of people were contacting me because
a school in my neighborhood in Cony
Island literally there were Asylum
Seekers sleeping in the school so
parents couldn't send their Scholars to
school which is depriving students from
their education which is a very big
problem yeah I mean that backs up what I
think all of us who spend time in New
York have experienced personally um
let's let's move on um you know the uh
Brownsville Texas always seems to or
Texas Deborah always seems to get
something first we actually don't hear
about Brownsville as much we hear about
Eagle Pass we hear about Del Rio we hear
about other sectors you're right there
at the tip um take a look at the numbers
of Migrant Encounters of the Southern
border up from 300,000 in 2017 to 2.4
million in 2023 300,000 to 2.4 million
what does that mean for your community
in
Brownsville well I can tell you well
looking um back at what happened to us
during the months of May and June we had
um Crossings like we had never seen
before um personal experience having
been over in that area myself numerous
times yep right there I've been right
there with the video they're showing
that area in one um I I don't even know
it was such a short distance we took out
10 tons of trash 10 tons of trash less
than a quarter mile that we cleaned up
um so what happens is they they cross
over and they just drop everything as
soon as they get to our side and I'm
talking anything and everything clo yep
there's our picture it's horrible we had
it took two days two days just to clean
that little area up um when you talk in
terms of our city uh just the other day
I was driving dropping my son off at
school and there was just five illegal
immigrants walking the fence line of my
son's school with their bags of clothes
uh just less than a couple days ago
driving and in area which is a
neighborhood they were walking down the
streets yeah I've had people call me and
tell me they're panhandling outside of
their businesses maybe not so much at
this current moment as when we first saw
that large influx back in May June but
I've seen that in Texas they're
everywhere Deborah I've seen that and
the truth is I've seen you know what
Ashanti is describing as well I mean
I've seen the kids who should be in
school who are now on subway platforms I
mean they should be in school in their
home countries but they're in this
country on subway platforms begging
which isn't a good situation for the
community or for the kid but Sam the one
community that I haven't been to is
yours I hear about it I hear your mayor
I hear people finally starting to wake
up in Chicago it seems like which has
styled itself as a welcome place for
legal immigrants all of a sudden saying
oh maybe this isn't such a good thing
for
Chicago uh yeah Chicago definitely the P
the resources that is long needed for
these communities you know 40 million
dollars a month being spent on migrants
that money is needed for educational
programs family train tring orientations
I mean just last week we saw uh two
executions where four teenagers were
murdered because we don't have the
resources but yet we have the resources
for um undocumented oril or new migrants
that are coming into into the city uh
definely this has to stop if federal
government is not opening not opening at
all I mean the city is in crisis we're
worried about the summer coming up the
uh Mo most of these migrants are
unidentified we don't know who they are
we seen in New York they commit crimes
they're willing to attack police they
shot now they travel to California
supposedly they could do their so we're
delivering the wrong message they could
commit crimes in the United States and
not whole be a whole accountable and you
already had a crime problem in Chicago
you already had a crisis and you're
pouring gasoline on a fire there in
Chicago uh we we we do and sorry to
interrupt you we we do we do have a
crime I mean I mean we're definitely
working on getting things better but we
need to change we need to win elections
to to win good legislation and we
haven't done that yet we're we're on a
process
Sam Deborah Shanti thank you guys for
getting up and sharing with us your
personal experience here on this crisis
all right thank you for having us I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis